all right tonight we have a brand new
example of just how despicably low the
hate from media will go at every cost to
try and damage this president now they
corrupted abusively by his press is
exploiting former Trump adviser Sam Nunn
Berg to help do their dirty work now
never mind the fact that this guy Sam
number was in the middle of what is
obviously a complete and total breakdown
after getting served a subpoena by the
special counsel robert muller now the
media didn't care about any of that they
cheered number --g of course they were
cheering him on because he was attacking
the Trump administration during a series
of what a really incoherent interviews
what's the exploitation by do I have to
give them my personal communications
Steve Bannon Roger stone Rogers my
mentor I email re with Roger 15 times a
day
for Sarah Huckabee to start criticizing
me I would say and I know what and I
know you may not like the way I say it
she should shut her fat mouth the you
should shut up Frank you're in the eye
of a storm Erin shut up she should shut
her mouth let me ask you the important
question yeah do you understand and I'm
warning her by the way to shut her mouth
Roger may be very upset
a lot of people may be very upset I
don't think this is this has been done
before they're not gonna send me to jail
you know what mr. Muller if he wants to
send me to jail he could send me to jail
and then and then I'll laugh about it I
think it would be funny if they arrested
me really really funny if they wanted to
arrest me because I don't want to spend
80 hours going over emails I had with
Steve Banta Roger stone talking to you
yeah I have smelled alcohol on your
breath well I had a drink you have
another drink so that's not no my answer
is no I have not
anything else no no no besides my meds
okay antidepressants is that okay you
know you would think of Erin Burnett
over a fake news CNN if she smelled
alcohol on numbers breath maybe she
would have maybe not put him on the air
but that wasn't the point of what the
media was doing yesterday they didn't
care this guy was literally melting down
on national television because they were
using him as
a tool to attack the Trump
administration it didn't matter if
nunberg wasn't making any sense that he
was contradicting himself or perhaps
intoxicated because the media saw this
is an opportunity to attack the
president and they seized on it just
like they always do here's another point
while the mainstream media was obsessing
over none Berg's freakout they
completely missed huge developments in
stories they should have been covering
like irrefutable concrete evidence of
real Russia collusion it's pretty
shameful complete disservice to you the
American people but we do know the
liberal media in this country they
stopped caring about the truth about
facts a long time ago and it's why the
so-called facts first Network fake news
CNN they will go anywhere in the world
to try and prove their trump Russia
collusion conspiracy theory to be true
okay
I'm not making this example up it's true
from fake news CNN they actually sent a
reporter to Thailand why to interview a
jailed Russian prostitute
/ sex coach who's claiming to have
information about 2016 election and
appearance now CNN couldn't bring in a
camera in the prison but here's what
they reported you didn't did you miss
this I just came out of this Detention
Center where I spoke with Anastasia by
shukhevich it was loud and hot and
chaotic and talking through the bars she
says that she witnessed meetings between
the Russian billionaire a leg Deripaska
and at least three Americans who she
refused to name she claims they
discussed plans to affect the u.s.
elections but she wouldn't give any
further information because she fears
she could be deported back to Russia let
me get this straight CNN sins were
reported at Thailand to interview a
prostitute / sex coach in jail who
claimed to have the smoking gun about
the 2016 election well that's news more
like this is CNN look if you're
surprised by CNN's latest on to prove
the so called Russia collusion you
should not be because CNN literally went
dumpster diving last month in st.
Petersburg Russia outside
a building that was reportedly home to
the troll farm that tried to influence
the election you can't make this up take
a look it looks like it spot of styrene
wrappers for some sort of computer or
electronic electronic stuff that's been
been delivered there recently in fact we
saw them taking out the boxes from what
look like new computers that have been
delivered there little dumpster diving
let's see Sex coaches prostitutes we
have a newsflash for CNN if you want
evidence of real Russia collusion real
crimes that are committed you don't have
to waste your time travelling around the
world and diving in dumpsters and go on
to jail to meet sex coaches it's right
in front of your faces and has been for
over a year we own this program we have
been exposing how all roads in this
Russia investigation lead directly back
to Hillary Clinton she is at the center
of everything now you have the Clinton
bought and paid for
Russian dossier the lying dossier
Russian propaganda and lies John Solomon
reporting that that Australian diplomat
that started the Russia investigation he
has deep ties to the Clintons involved
in 25 million going to the foundation
then you got Sid Vicious Blumenthal Cody
Shearer they were feeding anti-trump
dirt to the Obama State Department and
tonight we have a major new update from
vet investigative reporter Sarah Carter
she's reporting that the house Intel
committee is now investigating former
Secretary of State John Kerry and his
possible role in the phony and
completely unverified dossier and as we
just told you Kerry State Department
they were receiving anti-trump
information from longtime Clinton allies
then investigate that CNN and former
State Department official member
johnathon winner he's admitting he met
with former British spy Christopher
Steele Plus former State Department
official Victoria Nuland she said that
Steele gave the State Department pages
of information that she apparently
turned over to the FBI so here are the
key questions what did John Kerry know
now when did he know it and did this
information from Steele and Clinton's
allies make it to his desk now the House
Intelligence Committee Chair Devon Nunez
he did send a list of ten key questions
about that dossier to former Obama
officials but it's unclear
John Kerry is one of them now Sarah
Carter will reveal all in a report
coming up in mere moments and also right
now even more evidence that the fix was
in for the FBI's corrupt Clinton email
investigation tonight Fox is reporting
that Trump aiding FBI agent Peter struck
he was told that Hillary Clinton's
private server may have been hacked but
then he didn't do anything about it just
more proof the FBI did not ever at any
point conduct a real investigation that
the fix was in
and it was rigged from him for Hillary
Clinton in the beginning we do know that
call me and struck and others they were
drafting the exoneration statement
months before interviewing Hillary
Clinton and 17 other key witnesses in
that exoneration letter they changed the
language that said it was reasonably
likely that Clinton's server was hacked
and it was possible the server was
accessed by hostile foreign actors hmm
maybe Russia think about it for a second
it was previously reported that five
foreign actors had hacked Clinton's
server what we can guess one of them
probably has to be Russia another being
China possibly Iran was at North Korea
with all these people then had access to
top-secret material that means American
sources and methods were revealed which
means American lives were then put in
danger so struck put his personal biases
ahead of protecting Americans and
American national security while Russia
and others were literally looking page
by page and stealing our national
security secrets now what struck did
here is beyond a dereliction of duty
it's a crime which is why we have to ask
how does Peter strut still have a job
and better yet why isn't he being
investigated we now have a mountain of
evidence of bias and wrongdoing against
Peter struck and so many others and this
is only new information to add to the
list so it's time to hold him
accountable now we also have breaking
tonight the chairman of the House
Judiciary Committee Bob goodlet and the
chairman of the House Oversight
Committee trey Gowdy they're making a
joint plea to the Department of Justice
I'd like to join them requesting the
Attorney General jeff sessions appoint a
second special counsel to investigate
all this misconduct all this bias within
the Department of Justice and the FBI
now according to the request the second
Special Counsel would investigate FISA
abuses during and after the 2016
election including why the unvetted
unverified phony steel dossier how was
it ever able to be used to be obtain a
warrant against Carter page how did that
ever happen and as we said so many times
on this program a special counsels need
it they can't investigate themselves and
it's the Attorney General jeff Sessions
job to make this happen now finally
tonight after decades of inaction and so
much diplomatic failure that resulted in
a nuclear Iran North Korea Clinton's
bribery Bill Clinton's didn't work while
a breakthrough potentially is on the
horizon talks between North and South
Korea have been progressing and
officials in Pyongyang are now
reportedly opening to open to
renegotiating the
denuclearization in the region now of
course the Kingdom has also expressed an
interest in normalizing relations with
the United States has allegedly made
offers to end nuclear ballistic missile
tests and of course this comes just
weeks after the Trump administration and
acted tough new sanctions against North
Korea and Munson's president Trump moved
the third Carrier Strike Group to the
region now here's what President Trump
had to say about all these new
developments earlier today do you
believe in North Korea's recent
willingness to talk is sincere or is it
an effort to buy time for their nuclear
program and to what do you owe
this recent openness to talk me no I
think that
nobody got that I think that they are
sincere but I think they're sincere also
because the sanctions and what we're
doing with respect to North Korea
including you know the great help that
we've been given from China and they can
do more but I think they've done more
than certainly they've ever done for our
country before so China has been a big
help I think that's been a factor but
these sanctions have been very very
strong and very biting and we don't want
that to happen so I really believe they
are sincere I hope this sincere we're
going to soon find out now while these
revelations may present and represent a
potential diplomatic breakthrough it's
unlikely that the United States will
hold bilateral direct talks with North
Korea until Kim jong-un gets rid of his
nuclear weapons program I say that move
is highly unlikely beware